abby is a man of peace there are no
eritrean armies operating in english
right now how could you say this with
100
more than two years ago ethiopian prime
minister abi ahmed rode to power on a
wave of hope
for peace and democracy in the long
repressive country
but now he has waged a military
offensive on forces in the northern
tigre region
sparking a humanitarian crisis my guest
this week
from addis ababa minister for
democratization
where's the peaceful future his prime
minister promised
[Music]
minister zade gabraha welcome to
conflict zone thank you very much samuel
last year prime minister abi ahmed was
awarded the nobel peace prize and in his
acceptance speech he said the following
war is the epitome of hell i know
because i have been there and back
i've seen brothers slaughtering brothers
older men women
children trembling in terror now fast
forward one year later
he's led a military offensive against
the tplf group in the northern region of
tigrai
thousands are feared dead has he
led ethiopia into the hells of war that
he described one year ago
not at all abby is a man of peace
uh um you know he has deep convictions
and peace and ethiopia's opportunity to
be a peaceful country
because as you said he has gone through
such
ordeals such difficult times so his his
belief
on peace is informed by his own personal
experience
from the gate go you know it is not
average choice to go to
this wall abbey left nostron unturned
to settle the difference that
we had with the tplf
the tplf chose to give deep ears you
know tplf
was a guerilla fighting force
democracy is very aligned element
fortified
hippo life is used to set differences
by the muzzle of death dealing weapons
so no matter how
we tried to settle the difference
through their longing discussion
tplf gave chose to give
abby's plea for peace
and defeat and here we are and we will
talk about how you got here
in fact um but for now i would like to
just focus on the situation on the
ground because the u.n and ngos
they say that there is an urgent need
right now for independent monitoring of
the human rights situation
after the international ngo amnesty
international brought to the world's
attention
the massacre in my kydra they say the
following
that there are possibly hundreds of
civilians stabbed
hacked to death with knives machetes the
un says that if a party to this conflict
was involved it would constitute
a war crime again this is an
international ngo that brought
this incident to the world's attention
would it not be advisable to have an
independent international investigation
and monitoring
of what is happening right now in tigray
on the ground the days of us
were waiting for some western
institutions to come and
not uh were inaugural to
what we have done or not is gone
you know we have an independent
human rights commission came by the
former
human rights which the director for
africa his resume
is as as good as any in the world
he has his he has released his reports
which means
global standards and he can consult with
report
and i i i suspect that this question is
coming from
from the deeply held conviction that
africans cannot administer their own
issues
cannot build effective institutions that
are out there
to to impartially investigate human
rights
uh violations i think that the issue
that um is
is being brought up is is not that um
that that africans can't administer it
it's that
you are one of the parties to the
conflict in fact um and your
government's response in fact
to those calls for international
investigations has been and i'm quoting
here
we do not need a babysitter we will
invite assistants
only if the government feels that it had
failed to investigate
again you're one of the parties to the
conflict
that doesn't sound like transparency the
one who released
the investigation it's not us it is an
independent human rights commission
led by daniel bakala who was just
two years down the line head of human
rights which for africa
he is resume of as good as any global
standard so i don't think anyone from a
ministry international
or human rights which would be better
than
daniel beckham's credibility
and his investigative power so he hasn't
read the report
before asking any question i would like
you to go and read
his investigation so he just in case you
have questions
challenge him instead of blatantly
claiming that we are practicing the
conflict
daniel and his human rights commission
are not
parties to this conflict let's look at
some of these allegations
more deeply and i'd just like to take
you through them the tplf for example
they claim that your forces have been
party
to the violence refugees who have made
it to sudan they also echo those claims
for example cnn spent
a number of days interviewing refugees
who were crossing over the border into
sudan and they described to the
following
the ethiopian army entering into a town
telling civilians they are safe
then the soldiers leave and other armed
groups
such as the amara militia the fano
aligned with the ethiopian army
arrive there are concerns
that this is descending into an ethnic
conflict the conflict in tigrai
is the funnel being brought in to finish
the to grinds as one refugee described
it
that's very wrong amharan's integrins
have lived together for thousands of
years
wherever our army makes its way integral
people of tigra have been coming out in
months
in mass chanting and welcoming our
surgery
our mahara special police
defended himself tplf special police
attacked the mahara
uh the police crossing
the administrative delineation of the
ttla
the the tigray region so the
mahara special forces did defend
do you acknowledge the presence of the
whanau because a spokesperson for
example for your government
at first denied the existence of the
whanau militia but then confusingly
acknowledged that the militia of the
amhara region were engaged to the extent
of securing border towns between the two
regions and you have
refugees describing this this fear of
this force
are they there i know and the militias
are two different groups
fanu is a youth group the youth group is
not
anywhere integral it is a maharashtri
special the militias together with its
police were attacked by the tplf
uh military establishment and then
they were forced to defend themselves
that's what it is they are not killing
anyone
in fact we are rescuing the great people
from the tplf which was totally to
taking hostage of them
forever for more than two years so this
is not an ethnic
conflict this is rather a personal
oppression
there is no way for this conflict to
descend itself into ethnic this is not
even a civil war
by any standard let's look at another
claim um because you say that it's a law
and order operation as you've just
articulated right now
but there is growing fear that the
conflict in fact is drawing in regional
actors for example eritrea
um and could impact regional stability
the u.s cites the following
they say that they are aware of credible
reports of the eritrean military
involvement in tigrai and that they view
this as a
grave development as we mentioned
earlier
prime minister abe he made peace with
eritrea that is
part of what won him the nobel peace
prize are they now an
ally that has helped you fight your
military offensive
that's all you know our military
establishment
has been engaged in many african
countries and keep
in peace peacekeeping missions we are
capable of more than capable of dealing
with the tpla
so this is an insult to our military
establishment to say that
we are depending on the help of eritrean
army
i can assure you in 100 times in one
thousand one percent terms
there are no eritrean armies operating
in ingrain right i'm wondering though
how you can assure in 100
terms when the the americans say that
they have satellite images they say
intercepted communications anecdotal
reports from the region
also add to that um we know eritrea for
example just for context is a country
that has long faced accusations of
large-scale human rights abuses
and there are about 100 000
refugees that are located in tigris so
there's a lot at stake here
um the united nations says the following
over the last month we have received an
overwhelming number of disturbing
reports from eritrean refugees in tigris
being killed
being abducted being forcibly returned
to eritrea
and if confirmed these actions would
constitute a major
violation of international law these are
horrifying reports
can you not guarantee their safety and
how could you say this with 100 percent
we are the third largest host of
refugees globally
we are known for hosting refugees with
all due respect
that is that is very loud and wrong
information
the original refugees are
well taken care of here there if if
there is no editorial army operating
integrity
so there is no way for the eritrean
military establishment
to come and attack refugees if that was
the case
would have been the first to stand
against it
and then make sure that our refugees are
safe
that is very wrong that is their false
information you know with stephen left
gone
horn of africa is way better than ever
tibet live was one of the reasons behind
the unstability of the horn now
it is being reduced disseminated into
leaders running for their levels of
africa is safe
mr minister i'd just like to bring it
back to the actions of your government
though because um
your government says that it's returning
in fact eritrean refugees that had fled
in the northern region of tigrai
human rights watch um says that it's
unacceptable the u.n calls those reports
alarming um so you're essentially
returning people that fled in fear many
of them fled
went to the capitol they're afraid of
being exposed to eritrean violence
how do you explain that to the world
amid amid these reports
amid these fears from these refugees
we can only do anything with the
consultation of the refugees
chigra is now safe we have taken control
of the in each and every village of
uh tigris the sea all cities of digra
so you know refugees should stay in a
confine in a certain delimited place
we have uh well-built uh refugee
companies integra
and they are safe they are once again
safe
to welcome the refugees that's what it
is and it's not being done forcefully
ethiopian government believes in
consultation with refugees
it believes refugees need to be
respected
and their human rights respected so
that's not our reputation
we'll never undermine that you you say
that it's a safe and stable situation
but we have reports of
of four aid workers that have been
killed a u.n security team seeking
access near an eritrean
camp for refugees was also shot at by
your forces
that doesn't look good how is it
possible that a u.n
team could not be coordinated in the
region or are you afraid of
or were you afraid of what they might
see
if you are if you happen to read the
settlement issued
by the human rights
[Music]
just a day or two two days ago
they have asked for as an apology this
is a
technical problem the uk
staffers were not supposed to go a
certain place we are
building the british roads destroyed by
the tpl
we have established electric electricity
supply we have
established telecom connectivity road
connectivity
and our rv uh has liberated
the entire region from this junta
so it is safe for foreign the
international mu community mr minister
is not convinced of that the u.n says we
have reports that the fighting continues
between federal forces and the tplf
and affiliated militias on both sides
they describe the situation as worrying
as volatile as spiraling out of control
with an appalling impact on civilians
ultimately i'd just like to bring it
back to the fact that abi
has he he he has pursued a military
solution to this conflict
ultimately while your international
allies on the continent and beyond
have expressed a lot of concern they've
called for dialogue there was an african
union delegation
actually in the capital um that was
reportedly not even allowed
to meet with the tplf by your government
is that your understanding of more
democracy
blocking dialogue why not talk
okay uh for one thing i'm talking to you
from addis
i have what i we have ears and
eyes on the ground we know what's
happening you are taught to be from the
berlin probably and i'm telling you
tigra is safe
and i think it's good to to to
to take our uh for our take us for our
roads because that's true
you this is just a law this is a
protracted
flawed information that you are getting
which does not in any way
explain what is going on on the ground
dialogue can only happen
between two reasonable parties you know
for the past two and half years we have
been begging to believe to come to the
table
and settle our differences that is not
the assessment
um by the way of of others who are
following the situation because you came
to power
promising democracy promising peace
after decades of repressive rule
but in that transition chatham house
says the following that the lack of
inclusion has
angered the opposition groups with whom
the government has had
little genuine dialogue could you have
done more to bring the country together
for a more inclusive dialogue from the
very beginning could all the bloodshed
have been avoided
this government was able to broker a
deal with
eritrea and solved the problem
which was a long-standing one for more
than two decades if we can do with the
eritrea
we can do it with our brothers integra
we don't have a problem this government
you cannot accuse this government of
lagging
the culture of dialogue this government
is all about democracy reform in the
arrow
but the payload is not used to this
we're going to talk about it don't worry
you allow me i want to finish this it's
very important for us
tplf killed our soldiers
as they are asleep tplf killed women in
uniform at their sleep
which government will tolerate this will
your government will a u.s government
will a german government sit down with
al qaeda
no terrorist actions cannot be
participated mr minister
the international crisis group mr
minister the international crisis group
says the following that this conflict
runs the risk of ripping
the state asunder the tplf is vowing to
fight on there are reports of clashes
continuing on the ground experts say
we're seeing the beginning of a drawn
out insurgency
and yet your government is declaring
victory
you're saying that you have the
situation under control
after the offensive vermicelli your
prime minister even said
that that no citizen was killed
isn't your declaration of victory
premature
amid all of those assessments
we have the reports of the ground we
know what is happening
out there we are see there are simply
now less than 100 people running for
their levels
and we'll append them pretty much soon
the war is over mr minister
it is not just the region of tegra that
is a concern ethnically motivated and
inter-communal violence have been on the
rise
there have been reports of about 150
fatal clashes in the past year
some of those instant incidents have
estimates of hundreds killed
millions have been internally displaced
and now the united nations is warning
of a heightened risk of genocide war
crimes
ethnic cleansing crimes against humanity
when you look more broadly at the rest
of your country
are you on the brink of a potential
genocide
does the state run the risk of breaking
up are you the next yugoslavia
that is a very negative report of
ethiopia which is also against the truth
of the ground
we have more than a century dream of
making ethiopian state a democratic one
ethiopia is rather for the first time in
its history
has paved the road to make itself a
consolidated democracy
the rest of ethiopia is is more than
ever peaceful
ethnic clashes are not on the rise it
has in fact dwindled
four years ago three years down the line
we
had more than two million internal
displaced persons
now none of them are displaced they are
back to where there is
where they used to live and living a
safer life
so this does not represent does not
explain
the ground that is not the situation
that is described by international ngos
amnesty international reports
for example that your security forces
are part of the problem
they say for example in the region
in the region of aroma for example um
this is abi's political base they
they quote the carrying out of
extrajudicial executions arbitrary
arrest and detention
torture other forms of ill treatment
forced evictions destruction of property
human rights violations serious
accusations
they've called on your government to do
more to stop it where's the action
you know if ethiopia is ethiopia
ethiopia has
more than uh 110 million people
and most of ethiopia is very safe there
are
some uh armed insurgencies
on the western part of romeo now they
are decimated they are reduced to
very few in number if you see the
situation
four years ago they were by far
a thriving group now they have lost the
community has rejected them
it is the community itself that is
fighting against these people
we are not involved in extrajudicial
killings
there is a reform we introduced two and
a half years ago
close the chapter of us i'd like to move
on now to democracy because you're the
minister for democratization as we
mentioned in the beginning um
you've delayed the general election this
was your first
real shot at democracy after decades of
repressive rule
um now opposition political parties
mainly from abi's ethnic aromia
strongholds
they say they're being intimidated
amnesty describes the following
the crackdown on dissenting political
views ahead of general elections
the leading opposition figure has even
been jailed
how legitimate and democratic can your
election really be
amid what is being described as a
crackdown
it is not us that delayed the election
it is a national electoral board
led by with bertucca medexa a
non-opposition figure the most credible
uh personal political personalities in
europe
uh you know it is due to kobe 19.
more than 50 countries have delayed
their election beautiful 90
we are not an exception to the why are
you asking him is possible mr minister
i'm asking you this question because you
have
somebody who was detained and jailed
because he has a critical view
of your prime minister abi ahmed or at
least reportedly that's why he says that
he was detained
in fact there seems to be little
appetite to tolerate criticism even
abroad i'd like to bring you to another
case
and this is of the uk-based academic who
was among those who actually nominated
abi for his peace prize
he learned through reports apparently on
ethiopia's state broadcaster
that police had accused him of quote
using international media to destroy the
country
in response to his critical interviews
that he's done on international media
is this what opponents of your
government can expect expect in the
country he says he fears going back to
the country he thinks
there's a significant risk of him being
detained
you know this election is going to be
one of the the best and most democratic
election ethiopia has ever had
we have you know more than 20 political
groups were outlawed
we're forbidden to come to ethiopia we
have
lived that we have got rid of that
restriction they are now here in
in in town in addis in ethiopia moving
freely
we are assisting our opposition uh
parties to come together
to challenge us in this election we for
us winning or losing this election
is equally equally significant if if we
lose this election
we will be the first party to accept the
terms of
a true competitive election and hand
over power mr minister
how about press freedom in your country
the international federation of
journalists reports the following a wave
of arrests against journalists covering
the ongoing conflict in the tigrai
region
they say that since november 7th at
least six journalists have been arrested
on unknown charges
the ethiopian human rights commission
has expressed concern
there's also reports that the government
has repeatedly cut off the internet
journalists barred from traveling to
tigrai to cover
this this uh the election um that that
the tigrans had
back in september a new law
criminalizing hate speech apparently has
a provision
that can be used to lock up peaceful
dissidents is that how you define
democracy
isn't freedom of the press a central
pillar you know ethiopia
has more than ever committed itself to
respecting press freedom
in ethiopia there are no journalists
imprisoned because of the original
exercise a journalist a journalist can
happen to commit a crime on his
individual capacity not only on his
professional capacity
you cannot relieve someone from criminal
prosecution
just because he's a journalist
journalism
is not an immunity to run away from
accountability that comes out of
transgression transgression of the law
mr minister
briefly before we go it is not it's not
us that cuts internet integral it is the
tpl
that cuts the internet there is a
security camera
released two days ago showing tp-lf
officials welcome mr minister
mr minister you've cut the internet
before in other regions but briefly
before we go i'd just like to ask you
where is the spirit of medema the spirit
of coming together
and synergy that abhi described um that
he promised the country when he took
office
in this conversation we've talked about
ethnic violence a military offensive in
the north concerns that you are
backsliding on security and democracy
is this the best that you can offer
offer ethiopia
where's the synergy that was promised
avi is not
when whenever abby talks about peace
he's not giving a leap service
he's deeply it is is if he has a deep
connection
in ethiopia's opportunity to be a
peaceful country
so it is energized by
by the hidden potential of its
population
still will remain true to our oldest
ethiopians are united more than ever
ethiopians are happier more than ever we
had a challenge posed by the tpl
that was that became a roadblock and it
wanted
us to stop from marching to the road of
democracy this is what
what is happening with tpe left gone
ethiopians will be united more than ever
ethiopia will impress the etiquettes of
democracy the principles of democracy
more than ever
and ethiopians will be able to held will
be able to hold
the most peaceful the most democratic
election
of the nation ministers we have to leave
it there thank you for joining us on
conflict zone
thank you very much
[Music]
you